what I want to do in this video is think
about the types of questions that we
need statistics to address and the types
of questions that we don't need
statistics to address and we could call
the ones where we need statistics as
statistical statistical questions
statistical questions and I'll circle
the statistical questions in yellow and
I encourage you to pause this video and
try to figure this out yourself first
look at each of these questions and
think about whether you think you need
statistics to answer this question or
you don't need statistics whether these
are statistical questions or not so I'm
assuming you've given up a stat it not
unless we can we can go through this
together so this first question is how
old are you so we're talking about how
old is a particular person there is an
answer here and we don't need any tools
of statistics to answer this so this is
not a statistical question how old are
the people who have watched this video
in 2013 now this is interesting we're
assuming that multiple people will have
watched this video in 2013 and if
they're not all going to be the same age
there's going to be some variability in
their age so one person might be 10
years old another person might be 20
another person might be 15 so what
answer do you give here did you give all
of the ages but we want to get a sense
of in general how old are the people so
this is where statistics might be
valuable we might want to find some type
of central tendency an average a median
age for this so this is absolutely a
statistical question and you might
already be seeing kind of a pattern here
the first question we were asking about
a particular person there was only one
answer here there's no variability in
the answer the second one we're asking
about a trait of a bunch of people and
there's variability in that trait
they're not all the same age and so
we're only statistics to come up with
some features of the data set to be able
to make some conclusions we might say on
average the people who have watched this
video in 2013 are 18 years old or 22
years old or the median is 24 years old
whatever it might be
do dogs run faster than cats so once
again there
many dogs and many cats and they all run
at different speeds some dogs run faster
than some cats and some cats run faster
than some dogs so we would need some
statistics to get a sense of in general
or on average how fast do dogs run and
then it may be on average how fast do
cats run and then we could compare those
averages or we can compare the medians
in some way so this is definitely a
statistical question once again we're
talking about in general a whole
population of dogs the whole species of
dogs versus cats and there's variation
and how fast dogs run and how fast cats
run if we were talking about a
particular dog and a particular cat well
then there would just be an answer does
does dog a run faster than cat B well
sure that's that's not going to be a
statistical question you don't have to
use the tools of Statistics and this
next question actually fits that pattern
do wolves wait actually no this fits the
pattern of the previous one do wolves
weigh more than dogs so once again there
are some very light dogs and some very
heavy wolves so those wolves definitely
way more than those dogs but there are
some very very very heavy dogs and so
what you would want to do here because
we have variability in each of these is
you might want to come with some central
tendency on average what's the median
wolf wait what's the average the mean
wolf wait compare that to the mean dogs
wait so once again since we're speaking
in general about wolves not a particular
role wolf and in general about dogs and
we're trying to and there's variation in
the data and we're trying to glean some
numbers from that to compare this is
definitely a statistical question
definitely a statistical question does
your dog way more than that wolf and
we're assuming that we're pointing at a
particular wolf so now this is the
particular we're comparing a dog to a
particular dog to a particular wolf we
can put each of them on a weighing
machine and come up with an absolute
answer there's no variability in this
dogs weight at least at the moment that
we weigh it no variable in this wolf's
weight at the moment that we weigh it so
this is not a statistical question so
I'll put an X next to the ones that are
not statistical questions does it rain
more in Seattle than Singapore so once
again there's variation here and we
would also probably want to notice it
rain more in Seattle than say
poor in a given year over a decade or
whatever but regardless of those
questions however we asked it in some
years it might rain more in Seattle in
other years it might rain more in
Singapore or in if we just pick Seattle
it rains a different amount from year to
year in Singapore it rains a different
amount in from year to year so how do we
compare well that's where the statistics
could be valuable there's variability in
the data so we can look at the data set
for Seattle and come up with some type
of an average some type of a central
tendency and compare that to the average
the mean the mode whatever you want to
the mode probably wouldn't be that
useful here to Singapore so this is
definitely definitely a statistical
question definitely statistical what was
the difference in rainfall between
Singapore in Seattle and 2013 well these
two numbers are known they can be
measured both the rainfall in Singapore
can be measured the rainfall and Seattle
will can be measured and assuming that
this has already happened and we can
measure them then we can just find the
difference so you don't need statistics
here you can just you need you just need
to find you just have to have both of
these measurements and subtract the
difference so not a statistical question
in general will I use less gas driving
at 55 miles an hour than 70 miles per
hour so this feels statistical because
it probably depends on the circumstance
it might depend on the car or even for a
given car when you drive at 55 miles per
hour there's some variation in your gas
mileage it might be how recent an oil
change happened what the wind conditions
are like what the road conditions are
like of weather I mean there's you know
exactly how you're driving the car are
you turning are you going in a straight
line and same thing for 70 miles an hour
so when we're seeing in general there's
variation in what the gas mileage is at
55 miles an hour and at 75 70 miles an
hour so what you'd probably want to do
is say well what's my average mileage
when I drive at 55 miles an hour and
compare that to the average mileage when
I drive at 70 so because we have this
variability in each of those cases this
is definitely a statistical statistical
question do English professors get paid
less than math professors so once again
some all English professors don't get
paid the same amount and all math
professor
don't get paid the same amount some
English professors might do quite well
some might make very little same thing
for math professors so we'd probably
want to find some type of an average to
represent the central tendency for for
each of these so once again this is a
statistical question this is a
statistical question does the most
highly paid English professor at Harvard
get paid more than the most highly paid
math professor at MIT well now we're
talking about two particular individuals
you could go look at their tax forms see
how much each of them get paid and we I
guess especially if we assume that this
is in a particular year let's say let's
just make it that way say in 2013 just
so that we can remove some variability
that they might make from year to year
make it a little bit more concrete so if
this was does the most highly paid
English professor at Harvard get paid
more than the most highly paid math
professor at MIT in 2013 then you have
an absolute number for each of these
each of these people and then you could
just compare them directly and so when
we're talking about a particular year
particular people then this is no longer
a statistical question or it isn't a
statistical question